you
[Music]
okay so let's start welcome everyone
today our speaker is you Chang you Chang
did his PhD from University of Southern
California advised by Shang Wu Tang now
he's a postdoc at Duke University
you chains research interest is in
intersection of game theory and machine
learning and today he's going to tell us
about non convex matrix completion uture
thanks for the introduction and thanks
for having me here I really appreciate
you guys showing up here rather than
tending the other the retirement talk
next door and I'm going to try to wrap
up this as quickly as I can so we don't
miss the party so good this is a small
audience so feel free to interrupt and
ask questions and it's more I'm treating
this more as a seminar thing even though
the talk is recorded good so today I'm
going to tell you about non convex
matrix completion this is a joint work
was loan from Duke University so in
recent years a non convex optimization
has become quite successful in practice
you know like multi-layer neural
networks becomes the dominating approach
to many problems in computer vision and
speech recognition and many other things
however the theoretical analysis of non
convex optimization still lags behind
recently there has been a lot of
attention to try to improve our
understanding to non convex approaches
governed by this question basically can
we explain why they work very well in
practice and some of the question you
can ask in this regime for example you
could ask are all the local optima
approximately global optimal for some
given objective function and can you
understand the structure geometry of the
objective function can you use that to
design faster algorithms so this talk
half of this talk belongs to non convex
optimization the other half belongs to a
spectral graph theory for lack of a
better name
so the
it's a field that bridge together
discrete and continuous optimizations so
if you look at two separate fields one
is like graph theory which studies
discrete objects which has combinatorial
algorithms the studies graph trees Pass
flows and the other you are you have
like numerical analysis tools where
people do iterative algorithms look at
matrices and eigen vectors and together
recently there has been quite a lot of
success in combining these two fields to
produce faster algorithms for electric
flow say solving std linear systems max
flow better solver for linear
programming and many many other problems
so the other half of this talk would
belong to a spectral graph theory so
this is roughly where this work comes in
a high-level big picture so now I'm
going to dive into the act the problem
definition and what I actually want to
do about matrix composition good so in
the matrix completion problem you have a
unknown M by M matrix of rank R and the
input to the problem is a subset of
entries revealed to you sometimes people
assume it's uniformly at random
independently with some probability and
your goal is look at those entries and
try to recover slow rank matrix okay
this is a basic machine learning problem
that has applications to recommendation
systems and collaborative filtering for
example you could think of the rows of
the matrix and users and columns as
movies and if you observe an entry it
means in your system a user rated movie
gave some score to that movie and the
underlying low low rank factorization
just means every movie has some features
and every user has their preferences
good so throughout this talk we're going
to assume the underlying matrix is
incoherent that is basically to avoid
this the general case where there's only
it's a very sparse matrix somewhere is
one so the assumption just says all the
singular values should have similar
norms and we're going to assume all the
observations are noise noise list so no
noise added just try to recover this
matrix good so traditionally the most
classic approach to this problem at
least with theoretical understanding is
convex relaxation so you can formulate
this as minimizing the nuclear norm of
the matrix subject to that matrix agree
with all the observation you have okay
so nuclear norm is just the sum of the
singular values of n so what you
actually wanted to do is to minimize the
rank of the matrix subject to this
constraint but this is impure heart so
instead of minimizing like the l0 norm
of your singular values you just do l1
norm instead okay and you can show that
if all the entries are observed
uniformly at random and with sufficient
probability than this then this convex
program will give you the exact solution
will recover em and it can be solved it
can be basically rebuilt and as STP and
solved in time n to the four okay
not fast enough in practice so we're not
happy with that and that's why in
practice mostly people use our non
convex heuristics and the most intuitive
non convex objective function is just to
solve for a variable X that has the same
underlying dimension than the low low
rank factor and you just want to
minimize like the least squared error
with the observations so there has been
a lot of work on trying to understand
why a non-convex approaches works very
well for matrix completion practice so
in the beginning that the earlier works
focus on what happens if I can have a
carefully initialization mostly from SVD
so basically there are a lot of work
showed that if you start at the right
place then run gradient descent you're
gonna end up at the ground truth and the
later there are more work giving like a
framework based approach for this
problem that showed like strong
convexity near the global optimum so
that a lot of the algorithm would
actually work and more recently people
have been looking at doing just gradient
descent without some special
initialization basically start anywhere
and to show that this this function has
no bad local Optima I think Tommy Mao
was here presenting some of the work
about two years ago a year half ago good
right so basically these are some of the
previous work on convex and non convex
matrix completion but the crucial thing
which motivated our work is that all of
these papers are on this slide needs to
assume that all the samples are observed
are revealed all the entries are
revealed to you with the same
probability P okay and in this talk we
just want to ask the following a very
simple question that is what if what if
they are not observed with exactly the
same probability they're just observe
was at least probability P this is a
more realistic assumption in practice
because let's say a certain group of
your users might want to reveal a
certain subset of items more often than
the other people right for example maybe
you know man likes to reveal I don't
know something but and woman likes to
review shoes or something but so it's
very surprising to me at least why
people have haven't been asking question
this old assumption that the probability
are exactly the same
and on the other hand this is actually
very related to another model where semi
semi random anniversary can look at
which samples are revealed to you and
then review additional entry to
to try to introduce a bad local optima
in your objective function so the
question we want to answer here is are
the previous non convex approaches real
bust in this semi random model and if
not is there a way that you can fix them
but also still still make them faster
than their convex approaches okay
so this talk from now on this talk will
be these three parts so the first we're
going to show that to counter examples
to the the previous non convex
approaches basically tell you that it's
possible that they can get stuck in a
bad local Optima and even if you want to
do careful initialization with SVD it
might give you the totally wrong
subspace and then we're going to
introduce a pre-processing step that
tries to relate the entries so that the
input becomes random basically try to
undo what the adversary did to the input
and then eventually I'm going to prove
to you that after this pre-processing
step that the the non convex objective
function has no bad local optima good so
now let me first do the counter examples
okay so this is the recall the non
convex objective function so the counter
example just works like this I'm writing
them as two by two matrices but there
are actually block matrices so each one
should be multiplied by always matrix of
size n over two by n over two and P is a
probability that you observe this entry
basically you're you're much more likely
to observe entries from these diagonal
blocks than the off diagonal blocks and
X is the bad local optima that I'm going
to get stuck at which is roughly equal
to this number okay so the way we the
way we can verify that there is a bad
local optima here
is to basically say what's the
expectation of M star condition on the
revealed entries okay because the these
are these entries are revealed with much
higher probability this is what you
essentially get if you take the
expectation when when all the entries
are observed with the same probability
this expectation is exactly equal to M
star but now it's different and that's
essentially the reason why you can take
this matrix and the plug-in that's the
expectation of first order derivative of
FX is 0 and the Hessian is PSD that
means if P is high enough then there
will be a bad local Optima near X and
roughly speaking the reason why this is
happening is because the because the
sampling is biased so that the actual
thing that your observed is bias because
of P and u becomes a local sorry it
should be X so X becomes a a bad local
Optima because it's an eigenvector of
this matrix
it's not rigorously true but that's
roughly what's going on here yes why why
do we care and stuff because this is the
objective function that you're using yes
and
right basically you can take the
expectation of ethics
and the probability of IJ in that's
observed it's given by the big P matrix
and that's why the fact that these do
not that bad local optima is high
probability statement yes when P is high
enough then first of all if all the
samples are given uniformly I read that
when P is high enough that no you don't
have bad luck all so I just don't get
too late
oh it's not too bad to the arch they are
they are to it by two and I'm just
writing I write so basically all of
these matrices are n by n but I'm
writing out I'm partition them into
equal size blocks and I'm writing out
the number for that block you should
take that number and multiply the always
matrix and throw it in there I see
right
okay good so right that's that's roughly
what's going on so this is the first
counter example that shows when when I J
is not sampled uniformly at random then
this this function could potentially
have have a bad local optimum even when
P is very large and another example we
have in the paper that I'm going to omit
here is we have a 4 by 4 block matrix
that shows you if you do SVD on the on
the observed entries then that's not
going to give you the right subspace and
what I mean by that is the the angle
between the subspace and you get from m
dot P again this is like the expectation
that you observe and the true subspace
the angle between these subspaces are is
90 degrees they're actually all soccer
know each other
so these together are our you know bad
news and it essentially says you have no
hope of doing some careful
initialization because you're going to
get totally wrong in subspace and if you
start from a random point then you may
end up in one of these bad for coop tema
that's essentially induced by the
sampling probability matrix rather than
the ground truth questions
okay good so a good question so the
question is what about other approaches
if I don't want to do you know like
gradient descent on this function so for
example that the the first thing I
should say is convex approaches to work
the previous nuclear minimization
program faster works because given
additional entry would not change the
optimum of that function so that will
still give you the M star back Janardan
was asking about SVD it depends there
are some previous work on deterministic
conditions really like do matrix
completion on deterministic conditions
like but they they use convex approaches
as well but they didn't solve the entire
thing they used some other but yeah it's
saying the paper but yeah first for this
talk we're gonna specifically focus on
just do gradient descent on this
function and ask can you do something to
the input so that you can avoid the bad
local optimum okay good so now let me
tell you about our pre-processing step
so good so basically we will look at the
first counter example and ask ourselves
what went wrong so what happens is if
all the entries are revealed with the
same probability this is roughly what
you expect to see from a matrix but in
that counter example the diagonal blocks
are much more likely to be observed and
then the off diagonal block so you see
something like this okay and say if if
the adversary tells you that he's
changing the probability like like this
then what can you do can he do something
to to recover m star exactly so one
thing you can do is you can just you can
pretty much just resample this diagonal
block okay so for example you just keep
roughly 10% of the elements here right
then then what you get is essentially
like a uniform sample okay or more
generally you can try to put different
weights on the samples that you observe
so that's the weight that you get from
the diagonal and off diagonal blocks are
roughly the same if you do this then is
essentially it's like your samples are
coming from a uniform random
distribution and then you'll be fine so
the key idea of our pre processing
algorithm is basically to rewrite the
sample so it looks like a random input
and what do I mean by that is first of
all this is a weighted non coma
objective function so if you look at if
you take the graph view of this matrix
and say if I put an edge between node I
know J if that entry is observed this
matrix basically corresponds like this
graph okay so it's so it'll show a graph
with probability P but then anniversary
added some additional edge to form these
two very dense sub-graphs okay and our
algorithmic task here it's just to
recover recover a erdos-renyi random
graph basically this is a graph that's
like expander plus two clicks and we
just want to find some expander from
that graph and that's exactly the
problem we solve in the appropriate
pre-processing step okay questions all
right so the graph formulation is
following that you're given the graph G
that you know contains a sub graph
that's similar to some other graph H and
you want to rewrite G so that the
weighted version is actually similar to
H for matrix completion H is just the
complete graph or expander this problem
is as we stare at it it's very similar
to a well-established problem is a
special graph theory that is a graph
specification so graphs Parsifal is a
problem that give you a dense graph then
you want to produce some weighted sparse
graph that has some good properties that
have the same property say commute time
and a lot of other things with the
original graph and it's been first
proposed by spoon intent where they
showed that if you want two graphs to be
epsilon closing you need to take n over
epsilon square edges this tilde highest
poly log factors and M is the number of
edge
and is the number of notes and then in a
beautiful work of Batson Spillman's
reversed well they showed that you can
actually get away with an over some
square edges this tight and the running
time has then been improved to a nearly
linear time so the algorithm we use in
this paper for the pre-processing is
very is like directly inspired by the
recent advancement on this problem and
now I'm going to show you the formal
formulation for these two problems and
hopefully it's you should be convinced
that they are at their core they are
essentially this okay so this is the
structural specification problem I'm
basically taking the vectors and
multiplying each of them by L inverse
half that's the laplacian half inverse
1/2 power of the laplacian so that the
sum becomes our identity so the spectral
specification problem is I give you a
bunch of rank one matrices whose sum is
identity and I want you to find sparse a
set of sparse coefficients so that their
sum is approximately identity it's the
problem they solve the problem what we
want to solve in this picture is to say
that I give you a set of vector ax and I
promise you there exists a subset of
vectors that they sum up to approximate
to I and now I ask you to find a set of
weights so that I don't have the
sparsity constraint but I don't know
this hidden subset as well Jared are you
can see that there are some differences
between these two problems but I'm going
to explain to you why some of the
solution for the first problem can be
applied to our problem and some cannot
and hopefully that would be useful
you guys good question on these two
formulations well this is the main step
right yes without that in just
good the the pre-processing part is the
main contribution of this paper I think
that's fair main technical contribution
of this paper and you would also just
know I was I would say something at the
end but but this is like before before I
work on this that this is the part I
couldn't see the most and the rest are
relatively easier I'm saying yeah so did
you just say that problem 2 is not the
simple real quick right for example for
this problem and the very first
approaches are sampling by effective
resistance let's say okay okay
sparse vacation that is basically if the
graph is let's say the graph is nice
enough it's a complete graph then a
uniform sampling would work right but in
our problem there's an intuitive
argument why any sampling algorithm
basically shouldn't work it's because
the you can't check this promise right
in some sense well I mean you can check
by running this but when you're running
let's say you want to do if you if you
want to do a sampling by effective
resistance it doesn't make sense on the
second problems right you can probably
write right basically okay but basically
what happens in the second problem is
you have an underlying graph say your
expander and then that added some other
extra edges into this graph right which
causes spectrum to change for example
this graph is not expanding anymore it
contains the expander but it's mixing
time and these two cliques are much
faster than across the clinks and in
general the the underlying graph I'm
trying to recover may not be expander so
but but you know do okay
we can take this offline but but I hope
I can convince you at least offline that
- problem - is not a simple corridor
problem good alright so now let me take
a slight detour to tell you about how
people handle a graph specification
problem and why that routine is useful
for us okay yes why the runny type I'll
give you a nearly linear time algorithm
for a problem - well okay good
so for matrix completion problem M
doesn't have to be n square you only
need to observe roughly on logins and
login entries but the adverse we could
add a lot of interest to - your
important M would be n square maybe you
know or if the probability is higher
than M is n square then I'd I can't do
anything maybe I can do anything but in
this paper we don't study that we just
said that if you give me everything I'm
gonna read it in first thing you can you
can run specification first so you can
always assume M is roughly like an log
in a web some square good all right so
basically the approach in Batson
Spillman tsubasa is they're going to
maintain
partial the current some of these rank
one matrices and they're going to start
with a equal to zero and two barrier
values that basically sandwich this this
PSD matrix a so initially L would be
minus minus something I minus 1/4 or
something and you would be 1/4 so
basically right so basically in the very
beginning it's a zero matrix sandwich by
minus I and I and the algorithm will try
to add edge iteratively and
deterministically every time to grow
this ellipsoid while keeping it away
from the lower and upper barrier okay
the important thing for us here is the
only thing you need to know about this
algorithm is
they actually add edge deterministically
in each iteration and why they able to
show that it works is they can say that
a good edge always exists because you
can take an average edge okay so
remember in their problem all the
vectors sum up to I which means if you
take a tiny fraction of an average out
so basically you take a tiny fraction of
every edge then your ball then your
ellipsoid would just grow by identity
okay so you know that one vector is
going to help you in the right potential
function that you define so basically
you're going to start with basically the
the hope is the bet that the difference
between the two barrier barrier
variables are gonna stay the same but
the barrier barriers would advance at
roughly the same rate and grow larger
and larger and this ellipsoid will
become more like a sphere right that's
the idea behind PSS okay good and I want
to talk about this deterministically
part so basically the algorithm you can
directly be generalized to handle our
problem because this the argument the
good edge exists holds for us as well in
each of each iteration we know a good
edge exists as well because if you look
at a subset of the edges the average on
that subset is good even though we don't
know that subset but we know a good I
just do exist so you can basically just
apply BSS directly on our problem and
get away with that if I promise you the
the initial if I change this condition
to identity not approximately identity
then you can just apply BSS to our
problems and then you would then you
would solve this right good so the
conceptual contribution of the
pre-processing a part of our paper is
basically BSS is actually more powerful
than just applying it to graph sparse
vacation it's actually can be applied we
believe it can be applied very broadly
to a lot of semi random settings and the
technical contribution is basically two
things one is that like I said you no
longer the total sum of your vectors
along the longer identity so for example
that prevents
you from using some of those parts
application techniques and the other is
we need to go in and basically adapt the
analysis so that it works for this
approximately identity case so one thing
that we need to do for example is in BSS
you can control the upper and lower
barrier where to move at roughly the
same rate but now you need to take into
consideration like how close this is for
identity right basically you cannot hope
that these barriers would events at the
same rate because your underlying
solutions no not identity right so but
it's not very hard to take care of and
you can do that and that concludes this
part of the talk and before I move to
the next part let me tell you the
implication of this pre-processing
algorithm to matrix completion so
basically the entire argument of the
paper goes roughly like this now if P is
greater than some value say log n over n
then you know that there exists a set of
good ways why you can just put weights
one on the entries reveal by nature and
put weight zero on the entries that
later added by the adversary because a
good set of weights exists by this
problem that we just proposed you can
find a set of weights that that's close
to expander and then okay so the
guarantee of everything I've presented
just now is you can find this another
matrix tableau tilde such that it's
close to the all one's matrix in
spectral norm and you can compute it in
nearly linear time and in the rest of
the talk I'm going to try to give you a
sketch of why this condition it is
enough to prove that the non-convex the
weighted non convex objective function
has no bad local optima questions all
right so now we're moving to the third
part of the talk which is to actually do
matrix completion so again let's recall
this weighted objective function let me
rewrite it a little bit so I'm going to
rewrite it as the inner product of two
matrices which is just
basically you'd look at them as if
they're vectors but they're weighted by
W so these two are the same thing I'm
star is just Z Z transpose so the
previous non-convex matrix completion
work already tells us is actually
sufficient that you just look at the
first and second order condition for
this local optima in the direction
towards the optimum basically you're
just going to say I'm at here in the
optimum user and I'm only going to
examine everything as happening on that
direction and that's fine that's enough
to introduce a contradiction that X is
not our global Optima okay so this is
just a calculation you're just gonna
plug this in
just treat pluck act plug in X plus
Delta here and take all the first-order
term related to Delta you get this if
you take all the second term related to
Delta you get this okay
and if you stare at these first and
second order condition okay you know the
first order condition is 0 because it's
derivative zero and you know the second
condition second-order the hash in this
direction is at least zero a lot of
these terms are in common so you can
actually combine them and cancel them a
little bit
recall that Delta is equal to X minus Z
so let me use a some shorthand
basically a is the first order
approximation of XX minus Z Z and B is
the actual matrix which has this
annoying second order term and the first
order condition just says AP equal to
zero under W weighted by W and the
second order condition if you plug it in
across Z says this okay so this light is
my very poor attempt of trying to convey
to you how non-intuitive several
versions but now I'm happy to say that
it can fit in two slides but you might
need to stir it for some time to
convince yourself this actually works
like this ok but so far I haven't used
anything fancy I just said
look at the second and first and second
order condition in the direction of
towards the optimum and cancel a bunch
of terms and this is all we need to move
on
so B is just this thing the XX minus M
star thing we have okay so this is a
condition we have turns out from this if
if w is the all-wise matrix which means
the samples are uniform this is
sufficient to show that X X transpose
equal to M star and if you recover m
star exactly why is that because you can
show that the Frobenius norm of Delta
Delta square is the most twice that much
of this okay so I'm not going to show
the proof of this lemma but what happens
is essentially you need to find the
right Z to align to the basic given X
you are going to rotate Z a little bit
to minimize this Delta and then you can
do you can try to patch a bunch of
things in two squares and throw them
away and whatever left is this term okay
if you combine these two conditions
let's say W is all wines matrix see old
proof then that shows you M star equal
to X X transpose right because this
first term is going to knock out two
copies of this term here and then you
get minus M star minus X X transpose is
greater than or equal to zero so this
thing in the middle must be 0 and that I
believe actually shows you if you do
uniform sampling that's not true I want
to say that you don't need
regularization but you actually do if
the P is not large enough but it's so
anyway but in this work all that we need
to show is the for specific low rank
matrices like Delta and M star minus X X
transpose the weighted norm under W is
similar to frobenius norm when when
you're when you're taking samples
uniformly at random this is this just
follows from matrix concentration
inequality but now we need to replace
them with deterministic condition that
is the spectral norm between W and
J on once matrix is small and this is
the ulema
we use in the paper and basically like I
said it relates the norm of to the norm
of a low rank matrix under weight W and
the Frobenius more to the spectral norm
stated here and some other terms related
to like the max row norm of x and y okay
[Music]
this also justifies why you need to do
regularization because one of these term
come from the incoherence and the other
one is your your matrix and then you
need to basically take good care of it
so make sure it doesn't blow up but
anyway I'm not going to dive into the
detail of this but essentially this is
this is the most crucial thing that you
need to change in the analysis you need
to replace the matrix concentration
balance with this spectral norm
condition okay good and finally we get
that after the pre-processing algorithm
any local optima of FX actually satisfy
this condition it can recover the that
doesn't make sense it should be this
so my residual the Frobenius norm
squared of my residue is at most epsilon
of the original thing okay yeah I prove
this but yeah okay good questions
so why where do we get again the W minus
G is small because you because nature
revealed enough sample to you if you
only look at the sample from nature is
gives you an expander and the
pre-processing algorithm can recover
each vendor from expander plus garbage
and that's why first geezers just trying
to understand Jake J is no W does do you
agree scale for you so W is any now
negative weights you can put on the
samples no W is like 1 over P times yeah
yeah but you're right you need to be put
in somewhere right we put it in
yeah I'm happy to tell you more good
okay now I'm just gonna conclude so
basically our main results are our
threefold first is we post and studied
on comics matrix completion and
basically question this commonly used
assumption that p IJ equal to P and we
say at least P what happens and we show
counter examples that the existing
non-convex approach would not work and
then in light of this negative results
we propose a pre-processing problem and
we show that you can solve this in
nearly linear time and get some good
spectral property from from your weight
matrix and then using that property you
can show that the non convex objective
has no bad local optima so you can just
run gradient descent or alternative
minimization on it and you would be fine
good so the main the other main
conceptual contribution of this work is
basically we're trying to bridge
together two relatively young field one
is spectral graph theory that develops
fast algorithms based on the connection
between diskin discrete and continuous
optimization and the other is
theoretical analysis of non convex
algorithms basically in this work we
showed that you can get a fishing
algorithm by mostly using non convex
approach but wrong a very lightweight
convex optimization in the beginning so
you sort of like get better out of post
good ok open problems so I have two of
them one is that Ashley this should be
exact recovery we there is something
that I'm sweeping under the rock here
previous results were able to show that
if P is large enough you can actually
exactly recover m star but in our people
who actually we can show that and I have
a counter example of that actually being
false so you cannot exactly recover it
exactly you can only recover it up to
some
longing for Venus more and behind that
is really this question is how much how
much samples do the anniversary needs to
reveal to you so that you can actually
get stuck in local minima that's close
to the global optimum
okay and we don't know the answer to
this question what we're really hoping
to say is that they are very can must
reveal say like what I really want to
say is 50% of the samples needs to come
from the anniversary for the anniversary
to mess you up okay if only 1% is coming
from the anniversary then you are still
fine
I want I really want to prove that
statement but I couldn't so this open
problem and then I think that the more
important one is their conceptual one
that is can you apply the the Batson
Spillman through Basma framework or
packing sdp solvers in general to more
semi random problems and I know the
question is yes so I know one other
problem that you can apply this to and
I'm pretty sure there are plenty more I
mean it's just packing STP solvers so
now you can solve them fast enough can
do magic with them in the practice and
that's it can you get anything if you
just get a few fraction of your matrix
but it's not
well for example if I never I'll observe
entries from one row or column then
there's no hope I can recover right even
if it's rank one so that's that's also
and there's you need to be right so it's
a good know because for example you
could have if you only observe entries
from the diagonal blocks then you can't
do it right the way I think about is
like think of the rank one case what you
can really do is if you observe these
three entries and you can in fact this
triangle thing if you have two edges
then you can recover the third edge so
what you're really saying is your graph
needs to be connected in some sense but
every node has degree at least PN
doesn't guarantee the graph to be
connected right so you need be careful
about what conditions you put on this
all right thanks very much